this Mansion is unhinged
these ghosts definitely don't want to
leave
death lurks around every corner
hello hello hello foolish Mortals
welcome to Fandango's Big Ticket
interview I am your ghost host Nikki
Novak and I am defrighted to be here
with the cast and director of Disney's
Haunted Mansion hi she's funny
[Applause]
I am so ready Justin you obviously
understood the assignment because when I
saw this trailer I have not seen the
movie I was like oh my gosh so many
little fun Easter eggs in there but what
I cannot believe is that you actually
worked at Disney this was your summer
job this is the ultimate in
manifestation or or Serendipity or but
was there anything from that experience
as a team that you actually brought into
directing this film yeah I mean for me
uh I wish I was a teen it was a little
bit later I was in film School actually
and uh I felt one very nerdy for being
that excited about working at Disneyland
uh it was very I was very different from
my other like film school peers in that
way but there was such a
there's something so immersive about the
way those rides are built and the
Haunted Mansion is one of those rides
and I was just like every time I walk
past this one step I get goosebumps it's
like clockwork it's a kind of
Storytelling that like I was so excited
to figure out a way to like come up with
a cinematic equivalent to because it's
it's it's its own thing and there's
nothing like it in in the world what was
the step
oh gosh so for me I mean for me in the
Haunted Mansion is of course when you
get locked in that first room and the
stretching room when you start to stress
it's like I you just really feel like
you're in a different place they they so
completely take you outside of reality
and I just think that was you you
haven't seen the movie I haven't seen
the movie
and that that especially I mean the
movie is great everything you've done
you captured I mean Blended the humanity
in the ride but that scene in the in the
strut in the that that's the one that we
always remember when we walk into the
Haunted Mansion and and the first time
I've been there dozens of times because
I have three kids uh it did Park but
when that when those walls start going
and everything starts perspective
changing man you really did you you
knocked that one out of the park
where's our you're clapping you all have
the rest of you've all seen the movie so
how amazing is is it how I mean it's
like unhinged just the word in the
trailer for The House how honest is this
movie The thing about it is it's scary
but it's you know you get the
individuality with with Justin's good at
and a lot of things he's good at but in
that idea of allowing the characters to
come through I mean you really get the
feeling of the house and that is like
because when we went there it was
immense that thing was big you know you
can believe it but but what comes
through in the film is everybody's
individual character who have all kinds
of problems that kind of meld together
and synergistically in the ultimate like
experience of the Haunted Mansion I like
what you did there with the pun
through that was
very good
it's funny y'all and you'll have fun
yeah like I'm not always the biggest fan
of scary movies because I want to like I
want to laugh but I also don't want to
be like scared scared but it's like
scary enough
where it don't make you like oh I gotta
close my eyes but just like ah I can't
be present for this and I feel Joy in my
heart while they're going through all
this yeah I felt a lot of Joy personally
what is everybody's favorite ghost in
the film because there's 999 hunts in
the ride I want to know from you Justin
how many haunts are there in the film
and from the rest of the cast your
favorite ghost in the film well they're
exactly 999 in the film no I don't know
I gotta say for me is the Mariner goes
like I don't know why there's something
about that painting uh there's something
about uh being lost at sea that just
kind of speaks to me
um and uh and I felt like look I think
this movie is a lot of things it's a
ride but it's also about this man this
young man who is moving through
something kind of emotional and his
ability to feel his feelings is what
this movie hinges on and you know the
sea and water and being lost at sea is
such a beautiful I think visual metaphor
for like feelings and tough feelings and
I don't know it's like there's a moment
when when the kid's character Ben locks
eyes with the Mariner and and that's
that moment for me is like kind of how I
felt in this process it's like there's
something we're channeling here that's
just a little bit special you know yeah
I'm a big fan of things that are true to
Source material and I I you know I
experienced the ride because that's what
it is it's an experience it really is
you or it's unlike any other ride I
think it's it's it's real fun to go
through so seeing that that the story
that I was given paid close attention to
detail in that way it really excited me
because I don't I don't enjoy seeing
things that aren't the same as the the
thing that I enjoy but at the same time
uh to Justin's point there was rich deep
storytelling and characters that were
compelling and the way that that was
able to be merged and married together
was unique and I hadn't read it in a
script in a while so it was it was
really profound to come across this and
it is it feels unsettling in just the
the right way and I appreciate Disney
for taking a step to do something
different different in terms of the
storytelling in terms of the casting in
terms of the director this is a fresh
new take on something completely
different than the original
um and we're grateful for the original
but this is something that stands as its
own beast and I'm really happy to have
it and then sparring with people Danny
and Owen oh my gosh the scene with the
two of you with the police sketch and
Danny your impression of the Hat Box
Ghost with the lip I'm gonna do it I
know my mom did the impression you know
what I mean
just based off of the trailer such an
amazing scene what about you favorite
ghost my favorite ghost is the horse
yeah I like the horse
you know and me being a unicorn and all
I just really can relate
[Laughter]
oh yeah I forgot my favorite ghost is
also the Mariner it is when you locked
eyes that was it right yeah yeah I do
like the metaphors of the ocean and
being like water today I was like I had
like my nerves were a little you know
starting with with pressing everything
and my friend was like be like water and
it reminded me how water is such a
metaphor for so many things and it's a
scary thing feelings yeah they flow like
they're scary man I don't like to be on
the water
oh yeah it's scary you get into a storm
that was like what like we you captured
in the movie basically you're in a store
you know there's a scene that we won't
talk about because you're going to see
the movie but there's a storm scene in
this damn movie I mean that is big and
that's like you know you look at uh if
you've ever seen like ships out in the
sea or or uh you know oil rigs being
bashed by the ocean water scary as hell
I want to say where it was at but I'm
not going to say it because you've got
to go see the movie to find out but my
favorite there's a couple big jumps in
the movie but one of them was that that
damn bride
you know I mean that that was like that
was scary and there's some weird looking
people in it it is a weird looking
ghosts I mean you know like with Owen
they look like they're understanding him
but they don't give a damn
after him anyway that could be the
catchphrase for the movie The Ghost they
don't get it you know you're in there
they don't give them that
I mean I saw the movie at 10 o'clock in
the morning and ended up calling
everyone to just gush about the
chemistry and the energy and just the
how just perfectly they embodied their
characters they're such brilliant
moments of just growth and development
and like nuances to each of these
characters in the midst of all of this
story that was like can be really
emotional and suddenly pivot very funny
there's this very striking scene with
you know the kids talking about these
memories and it gets super emotional I'm
literally starting to tear up wow and
then you cut to his face and his
reaction to the story and you're like
how are we going from crying to laughing
like this and you've got jump scares and
all kinds of stuff that go on so the
movie is just it's a ride it feels like
a ride and and I think that you know
talking about making that interpretation
of the feeling of being in it you know
this was Walt Disney's I think one of
the last rides that he ever approved of
um it didn't even go into use until I
think two out two years is after his
passing and it's so interesting reading
about the history of it because there
was such a fight internally about like
how scary do you make it or how funny
and spooked like is it scary or spooky
and what you know what that line is and
I think you know Justin you did just a
brilliant job of like holding that line
uh throughout the entire film and so
it's it's great and so for me the ax
bride is the same for me you know
because we did a lot of stuff
practically
so you know these are folks who are
running around with prosthetics on and
these incredible costumes that Jeffrey
did and you know it's just looked so
cool on the day but then like millions
of dollars later when you add all the
special effects to add it to actually
have them flying around and that ax
flying through the room it's scary like
it's like it went from you know it was
so it's just a great balance like I it
was really thrilling and I was just
laughing about how what a great time I
had watching this movie at 10 am and I
will ask only you you have Ahsoka coming
out another Disney project your favorite
Force ghost
oh my goodness
um I mean I think that's got to be uh
that's got to be Anakin for me just
because I I'm looking at the history of
it he didn't even know that's what he
was filming apparently and they threw it
in so he's all Smiley and stuff and they
just put it into the movie and he
apparently didn't know that and was like
oh if I had known I would have portrayed
it a little differently but he just like
caught like I guess George just got this
extra scene of him and just sort of
threw him in there which I just think is
kind of amazing so I like the very
reluctant when it goes you know very
reluctant Force ghost
um I want to ask you about acting
opposite Jamie Lee Curtis's head as
Madame Leona I mean Jamie look at
Curtis's head right off he'd like to
bring her in
we couldn't get her body yeah but we got
her head so that's all we could afford
yeah I think Justin said that you two
were like the most unexpected Duo
together so how did that sort of work on
the day I know you shut a lot
practically like did was she sort of
like under a table with you know CG
afterwards or how did that work it was
like she was in a chair and then she had
to like be really still here and it was
Rosario and I like that was like feeding
her lines Justin was feeding her lines
too I think we all wanted the
opportunities we acted directly with
genuinely yeah
he was like jumping down to do Danny's
lines coming back up like this like
trying give her eye lines for stuff we
were so excited we were doing a lot it
was the best and she's so funny so fun
and so easy to talk to and then her and
Danny were telling me the best stories
of the day we were doing the green
screen stuff oh you guys and we can't
repeat those stories
and it was a lot of fun she's so awesome
and she returns text messages and she's
an Oscar winner I forgot to enter to say
Oscar dinner Jason right that's right
that's right Justin what a cast you
assembled for this movie I I wonder if
you've ever seen the Met Gala of Jared
Leto carrying his own head up the red
carpet because it's very happy of course
I've seen it is that why you cast him in
this film honestly How deep did he go
also because he loves to be
unrecognizable and everything I promise
you if you did not know specifically
that this was Jared Leto you would never
guess who it was okay like like one of
the things about the movie and and
Rosario talked about this already is
like the ride has this quality where you
know something you know a trick has to
be played here but you cannot quite spot
the edges you can't quite figure out how
they're doing it and and the hatbox
ghost character is very much that you
it's it's part man it's part you know
CGI it's part practical and the voice is
just incredible but there's he comes he
literally transforms uh in this
particular role and for you how many
because I can just tell even just by the
the footage and the trailer I've seen
how many Easter eggs you put in this I
know Disney gave you the Bible they took
it behind the scenes of the ride can you
tease like an Easter egg or something
that you were like I have to put in this
book honestly like everything I could
because I'm a you know I'm a fanboy like
I come from that fandom culture okay and
especially with something like this I
was like it only gets richer the truer
we are to the source because the source
is inspired like you were saying like
there was a fight to figure out what the
tone of this thing should be and that
fight that tension creates something
really magical about it so I mean
everything down to like the paintings
that were gone and then came back into
the ride like I was like clocking those
like okay we got to put that in a
prominent spot everything down to the
doorknobs okay the way the the doors are
framed certainly the wallpaper had to be
right the ghost had to be right and the
other thing that I wanted to bring to it
is like a real sense of cultural
culturally being really placed in New
Orleans like it was really important to
me that like you know we say this house
is in New Orleans New Orleans is a very
black City and it has many different
cultures that come together and mix and
and find this kind of Harmony together
and I absolutely wanted to infuse you
know that sort of authenticity into the
ride too I want to tell ghost stories
because I think I'm uniquely qualified
to do this interview because there's a
moment like Keith where your character
has a ghost possess him in the trailer
and goes through his body and this
actually happened to me in Tokyo where I
was like I literally had a ghost pass
through my body I'm not crazy I I wasn't
okay we're done
start with you Danny
don't start with me please I God I am a
ghost
I'm haunting you all
if I told you my ghost stories
I would probably just disappear right
now because the ghosts
I can't say okay I can't even talk about
them there wow
wow well this is getting real yeah they
make him signed a ghost
it's even worse than that it's not even
yeah it can't even it's not yeah it's
like you can't well I love the uh the
metaphor for soul reaping something that
me and Justin talked about early on that
Ben is on this journey to find himself
find his soul
um he's going through mourning um at the
beginning of the story and he has to
sort of reposition himself in life and
find his feet after a terrible loss and
it's a difficult thing for a lot of us
to deal with I identify with that
struggle and navigating the harder
moments in life to try and find your
your true self and so he had to give up
some things that no longer served him to
let in things that did serve them so he
could find himself and be the person he
wanted to be that at the center of the
story was really important for me this
is not just like cheesy scary ghosts
this is a real meaningful story embedded
in in this in this film and that is what
really drew me to it in the beginning
and all of the little Trinkets and
treats and ghosts and VFX is all just
serving that Center story that that
serves as a spine and that's something I
really appreciate well I will end on a
meaningful question then there is a line
in the trailer that you say are you sure
you want to enter this house because it
will change your life and I'm sure as
actors every step that you enter changes
your life in some way so I'm wondering
how this experience of working together
and working on this unique film changed
you as performers
well they just get to be seen
well I'm a lot more patient now and I am
psychic I'm a Tarot reader check my tick
tocks out
I knew that was coming plug
Tiffany haddish it made me better I was
going through a personal transition in
my life where I was just really working
on my spirit and my soul asking these
like questions to myself about things
that I needed to unpack and working on
this film gave me the opportunity to be
focused on something that was important
that I felt was important that I had to
show up for every day and sort of rally
all the troops together and work with
these really talented people who I grew
up watching like like Danny and Jamie
Lee Curtis coming in someone who's a
really good spiritual beautiful person
if you get to know her you'll learn that
Rosario who's always a perfect example
of how to maintain balance in yourself I
don't know how she's always in such a
good mood it's a beautiful thing and
Tiffany who's always reminding you to
laugh and just you know stay jovial and
you know just just really have fun in
the process and so I couldn't be more
thankful for the group of people that I
was with love Danny I mean he just I
invite them to my parties now I think
the thing is that it it you know this is
like been said a million times but you
know you have a fearless leader and that
was Justin and you have people who are
really are dedicated uh besides Justin
who is totally immersed in this and we
all are we you know give ourselves over
to that sometimes you give yourself over
to the wrong person we give ourselves
over to the right person we were very
fortunate to have him also we have the
technology the people who did the the
the Jeffrey uh uh curl and forget about
it his costumes are off the charts but
but there's another Jeffrey Jeffrey the
DP
incredible who's whose work is like
magnificent in the movie and so that
combination it's always said to be a
collab a collaborative art everybody's
together in it and besides the fact that
we've become a family only the cast and
that I attribute to the director always
uh am I cooking and you're cooking oh
right I'm telling you that was like
whenever whenever she's cooking I'm
there baby I'm telling you and so all
that whole combination in this film in
in uh really worked very well and and
we'll all remember it forever yeah yeah
I mean for me it was like you know I had
come off of several projects that had
been very very intense a lot of ugly
crying and and I literally just put out
into the universe like I need to do a
comedy or something and then this showed
up and I just couldn't believe it and
then I'm with some of the funniest
people to ever exist on this planet and
was super intimidated but I have this
amazing young man in Chase who's playing
my son and we would have these scenes
where you know a lot of the times we're
watching these experts that we brought
into this house to help us try to do
their thing and the just the chemistry
between everybody and the fun of it all
and we would just be throwing our looks
to each other and just to see it play in
there and stretch myself because I don't
do comedy very often and it was just
really fun to kind of relax more you
know and play this very still very
tightly woven up kind of character and
just I just love the balance of her I
loved how strong she was I loved how
kitschy and weird and specific she was
and you know and I just really loved how
everyone jumped into their roles in that
way and just to be on set every day just
taking in people's process because
including when we watched Jamie Jamie's
there with dots on her face and just
doing this performance over and over and
over again this huge monologue that
she's doing and would just you'd give a
tiny little adjustment of a tonal shift
and it would be completely different and
it was just mesmerizing we'd be sitting
there staring at her and then go all
right we're supposed to be working with
us all right let's get it but it was
just like a notes all day felt like I
was taking notes all the time they know
how many pictures I was taking on set
watching between him and Owen fighting
it was like one of the most hysterical
things to ever witness in life I was
like yes please it just was really great
and so I just definitely want to shout
out to chase because he really is such a
huge heart in this film and what a
remarkable young man and performance
level and how just I mean I felt
intimidated at times showing up upset
and like really holding myself I mean
here's this child who is not a child
he's like a grown man in this child's
body and just holding his own and like
totally fearless and it was exactly that
kind of energy that needed to happen
with all of us we had it we had to
become more Fearless together as a
family in order to to have any kind of
Triumph and it was it was great to find
that with each other and he had a growth
spurt during the film he did it was so
his voice started changing we were like
he's like up here to me we're like this
house is going to work I'm like stop it
same note to chase was like remember
you're nine
funniest scenes ever is he supposed to
play with these action figures and he's
like what do we do and you're like what
do you mean what do you do play with
them he's like I've never played with
these we're like not shocked by that
whatsoever but we're gonna need you to
figure it out do some research he's an
old soul so it was perfect for this I
would let her fearless leader have the
last word about how this changed you as
an artist oh my gosh this was like my
first movie
I made it in 19 days with less than a
million dollars okay so to go from that
to something like this where I think we
shot for like 150 billion days I'm not
sure
um realizing that the job is exactly the
same but the scale uh is quite different
and the kinds of things that you have to
balance are very different and I felt
like I was ready for it but at the same
time I feel like I had to grow so much
every single day working on this project
I mean it's like a it I can't even I
couldn't have imagined the person I had
to become to complete this film when I
started it and uh and and that's like
Danny said that's something that like
I'll take with me forever I'm a
different director now uh having made
this film and for the better
thank you all so much I am possessed by
all your answers and by this
conversation and to all of you tickets
are on sale now at Fandango bring 999 of
your friends to go see this movie
[Applause]